- It's safe, I feel safe here.
- À la recherche de sécurité,
Tomas Olverda Ortiz est débarqué
à Montréal il y a une semai
Après avoir économisé
pendant deux ans, il s'est payé
un billet d'avion pour quitter
le Mexique et venir faire
une demande d'asil
Il veut travailler et
il est loin d'être le seul.
"Ils sont nombreux à être
hébergés ici, au YMCA", dit-il.
Depuis le début de l'année,
près de 8000 Mexicains ont
demandé l'asile au Canada
dans les aéroports canadiens.
Plus de 80 % d'entre eux
l'ont fait à l'aéroport Pierre--
Eliott-Trudeau à Montréal.
Un processus régulier
contrairement à l
du chemin Roxham, mais
qui semble organisé,
selon cette interv
EVA LOPEZ, dg, Intégration
communautaire des immigrants
- On a r'il y a une
certaine structure évidemment
qui est là. Est-ce que
c'est un système de passeurs?
Est-ce que c'est un systèmen sye
de bouche à oreille très amical?
On a aucune idée.
Ils arrivent avec un
objectif clair : travailler.
- Mais pour cet avocat,
l'objectif est d'abord
la sécurité.
Me ALFREDO GARCIA,
en droit de l'immigration
- Ce sont des gens qui viennent
demander la protection
internationale et tent
avoir un permis de travail pour
éviter de devenir un fardeau.
- Les conditions de vie
difficiles au Mexique,la positi,
les vols directs entre Mexico
et Montréal font partie
des pistes de réponses avancées
par ces intervenantspour exppoui
leur arrivée maintenant.
- L'honorable député
de Rosemont-La Petite-Patrie.
- Pour le NPD, c'est toutefois
la preuve des failles du sys
d'immigration économique.
- C'est comme si ces gens-là
savaient très bien que notre
système d'immigration,
d'immigration économique,
est tout croche, est chaotique,
les retards sont épouvantables.
- Mais depuis 2016,
le gouvernement Trudeau a aussi
aboli l'obligation de visas
pour les Mexicains.
Et pas question pour le moment,
dit le ministre fédéral,
de changer le système de visas.
Tomas, lui, est conscient
qu'il pourrait devoir
retourner au Mexique
si sa demande est refusée,
un risque qu'il est prêt
à prendre.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.